hey guys i'm nina dobrev I played Becky
- techie in XXX the return of xander
cage and we are doing the evolution of
the selfie it's come a long way alright
so first up we have the Nokia brick this
bad boy came out in the year 2000 you
can definitely tell it's a brick I think
even happens do they have cameras back
then oh yes there does there it is how
you do it standard photo portrait photo
nighttime mode let's your portrait
capture alright here we go
double gen send it again yeah there we
go alright
it's the Nokia brick okay next up we
have the Motorola PDA that's right like
public display of affection um a lot
bigger
I still can't wait for this baby anyone
that need help ok ok so I needed a
little bit of help there I know I played
Becky the techie but Dobrev is not
technically inclined in real life
there's no guarantee this will be good
to see the results it's a little better
ok so less than a year later Sony came
out with the Ericsson this is a flip
phone capture ok no next we have the lg
horizontal slider in 2008 and it
apparently Clyde's honey oh there it is
Lyons it's very
very tricky
like all the funny tones that they have
it's okay so up next we have this pink
little number it's a Motorola do you
guys remember the razor super exciting
at the time but it went away very
quickly okay we're just gonna now we
have the BlackBerry do you guys remember
these things way too many buttons
pictures were not great there's a
picture of a thumb in here that's weird
and they would always say like Oh cuz
you can send your email easier whatever
and the picture sucks the quality sucks
hate these things
bye I'm glad you got discontinued how
are you next we have the LG env touch
what does that mean I want to touch this
thing
is it silky smooth no it's actually
really really really coarse they made it
easier to get to the camera roll spoke
too soon it has no buttons this is the
first touch screen no it's not touch
screen phone goddamn keyboard it's not
even on take a picture
yep
so weird noise alright we finally
reached 2017 introducing thank you Steve
Jobs is the iPhone I'm not the biggest
selfie person like hey I really don't
like it when girls do that thing where
they like post a selfie in bed and
they're half-naked and they're like ooh
I just woke up with they're wearing a
full face of makeup get over yourselves
girls
wait boys ladies angle up nobody looks
good from this angle down here
put yourself a favor I'm such a loser
all right guys there you have it we went
from the brick to the iPhone I hope you
enjoyed it and I hope you picked up some
good tips skill an iPhone with the
camera op find your light you're welcome